I'm being a very frugal person or
someone call it being cheap my wife is
the kind of person where she prefer take
a big vacation every year and I'm the
kind of person you know I can go 10 15
years without taking a vacation in my
financial state right now can't should I
be able to or should I be a little lose
with my you know my money or should I
keep the way I have been doing it right
now we have a combined income of
$210,000 we have a combin of uh
retirement savings of
$315,000 I have zero debt you guys have
gotten out of debt you have your
emergency fund you make a great income
you have savings and retire like you're
doing everything right and you have the
ability there is margin there for you
guys to enjoy your life George you have
to enjoy your life